if your job is to try to be the best  basketball player you can be  all right to do that you have to  practice you have to train right  you want to train as much as you can as  often as you can  so if you get up at 10 in the morning  train at 11  right 12 say 12. train at 12. train for  two hours 12 to 2.  um you have to let your body recover so  you eat recover whatever you get back  out  you train start training again at six  train from six to eight  and now you go home you shower you eat  dinner you go to bed you wake up you do  it again right those are two sessions  right now imagine you wake up at three  you train at four go four to six  come home breakfast relax  now you're back at it again nine to  eleven  right relax and now i'm done you're back  at it again two to four  now you're back at it again seven to  nine  look how much more training i have done  by simply starting at 4